[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe pop est présent à 50 ans en
Yvelines depuis 2019 implanté dans le
campus du numérique à Élancourt il
propose des formations dans ce domaine
et poursuit les partenariats avec les
acteurs locaux le groupe japonais JST a
décidé d'implanter son centre européen
de R&D à Guyancourt leader mondial de la
connectique électronique cette
entreprise réalise 2 milliards d'euros
de chiffre d'affaires dont un tiers dans
le secteur automobile lucide d'Airbus
defense and space d'Élancourt collabore
depuis la crise sanitaire avec la
start-up reknorak cette société
implantée à plaisir et spécialisée dans
le traitement des déchets plastiques
pour fabriquer un matériau particulier
[Musique]
c'est une société qui est spécialisée
dans la connectique électronique qui a
été créée en 1957 par Monsieur takarachi
et aujourd'hui c'est madame nishimoto
qui gère la société avec son fils le
docteur nishimoto on est présent sur
tous les marchés électroniques vous
prenez n'importe quel appareil chez vous
que ce soit électroménager appareil
mobile un véhicule partout vous allez
électronique vous avez des connecteurs
JST c'est une société qui a été créée en
1957 qui a une part de marché importante
sur le monde de l'automobile où vous
retrouvez les connecteurs JST dans tout
ce qui est éclairage dans le tableau de
bord dans le système de sécurité avec
les airbags partout vous allez
électronique au sein du véhicule vous
avez des connecteurs JS
[Musique]
il est proche de nos clients savoir
c'était lentillesse Renault Valeo qui
sont des clients à fort potentiel pour
projet St et on développe un partenariat
depuis plus de 20 ans être proche du
client c'est vraiment dans l'axe de la
manière d'agir de la culture japonaise
au moins de l'entreprise c'est customer
nids c'est le besoin du client et client
a besoin d'avoir ses fournisseurs à lui
[Musique]
il y a un certain rayonnement du fait
que on est à 30 km de Paris que on peut
arriver à Saint-Quentin 100 feux rouges
par l'autoroute fait des éléments quand
même de compétitivité très content
d'avoir un acteur aussi puissant en plus
ça me sur des secteurs extrêmement
stratégiques d'ailleurs leur premier
client sont des clients qui sont à 50
ans en Yvelines devant sur l'automobile
ou que ce soit Validéo que ce soit tout
secteur automobile
[Musique]
qui en suit le planning on rentrera dans
les locaux au même moment que les Jeux
Olympiques R&D principalement centre
commercial européen voilà développé être
proche de du client aller voir les
clients pour pouvoir développer pour eux
de nouvelles connectiques électroniques
à l'intérieur de l'entreprise il faut
qu'on soit comme comme à la maison pour
être bien donc si on est bien au travail
on va fournir un travail de qualité
[Musique]
et dans le skyco nous sommes avec
Emmanuel Van Damme bonjour bonjour Alors
on vient de voir sur les images vous
venez de recevoir l'ordre national du
Mérite vous êtes le directeur fondateur
de du groupe pop le groupe pop un acteur
important de l'inclusion du numérique et
vous êtes présent sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et alors
acteur de l'inclusion du numérique c'est
large en quoi vous agissez là-dedans
tout à fait alors nous pop on a la
particularité d'agir sur toute la chaîne
de valeur finalement de ce qu'on appelle
le numérique inclusif c'est à dire que
on est des actions de médiation vraiment
pour aider les gens qui sont en galère
face à des démarches numériques ou qui
ont le souhait de monter en compétences
pour répondre à leurs besoins personnels
on fait de la de l'insertion et de la
remobilisation à travers un dispositif
qui ici sur 50 ans en Yvelines s'appelle
100% ensemble on accompagne près 1000
personnes en se servant du numérique
pour les aider dans leurs problématique
sociale les aider à retrouver un emploi
on fait de la formation avec pop cool et
en complément de médiation insertion
formation on a aussi un rôle
d'accompagnement des acteurs on
travaille des collectivités entre les
acteurs associatifs pour les aider à
mieux travailler sur ces sujets
d'inclusion numérique vous êtes un
entrepreneur social et c'est ce parcours
d'entrepreneurs sociales qui a été et
bien honoré ce soir tout à fait c'est
vrai que moi j'ai un long parcours
d'entrepreneurs social j'ai créé plus
d'entreprises toujours dans ce secteur
finalement du numérique inclusif je suis
vraiment persuadé que on est face à une
transition numérique qui touche la
société et qu'il est important
d'accompagner par des démarches
inclusives solidaires faire en sorte
vraiment que chacun trouve sa place dans
la société numérique la mission de pop
telle qu'on la définit c'est faire
société numérique et ça ça vaut pour les
habitants mais ça vaut aussi pour les
acteurs économiques pour les acteurs
éducatifs il y a un énorme travail à
fournir pour accompagner tous ces
acteurs dans cette transformation
numérique et ça typiquement c'est un
travail d'acteur de
solidaire d'entrepreneurs sociales on
est sur des domaines d'activité qui sont
pas forcément des domaines immédiatement
rentables mais qui répondent à des
besoins sociaux très forts et qui ne
font que se développer Emmanuel Van
Damme vous dites faire société du
numérique mais il y a quand même des
limites il faut pas aller trop loin oui
alors ça fait partie tout à fait de ce
qu'on fait sur numérique c'est le
numérique n'est pas une fin en soi moi
je suis pas du tout un prosély du
numérique je ne défends pas le numérique
dans tous ses usages il y a évidemment
des usages du numérique problématique
nocif pour la société il y a des des
externalités négatives du numérique des
conséquences environnementales
importantes l'important n'est pas de
faire plus de numérique mais de faire
mieux de numérique et de faire en sorte
que chacun utilise le numérique à bon
escient pour répondre à ses besoins sans
être finalement dépendant des
technologies mais en maîtrisant ces
technologies et là où je voulais en
venir en disant ça c'est que des acteurs
comme pop sont essentiels pour faire
comprendre
l'ensemble de la population tout à fait
c'est vrai que le rôle d'acteur comme
nous qui font de la de l'insertion de la
médiation numérique est vraiment
essentielle si on veut faire en sorte
que des territoires un territoire comme
50 ans en Yvelines par exemple 100 parts
vraiment du numérique ne soit pas
simplement un objet un marché du
numérique pour les géants du numérique
ce fameux gafam qui font peur un peu à
tout le monde il est important de
générer des services numériques de
proximité de ramener numérique au plus
près du territoire pour garder aussi la
valeur que le numérique permet de créer
sur ce territoire merci beaucoup
Emmanuel Van Damme merci je rappelle
vous êtes fondateur et directeur du
groupe pop et justement on vous dites
que ça se passe dans les territoires et
bien on va aller rejoindre tout de suite
romain blottaz qui est coordinateur de
pop school au niveau de l'Île-de-France
et qui est au quotidien qui s'occupe de
l'activité au quotidien de pop School à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous allez
voir tout de suite la transition dans
ces images
[Musique]
et le coordinateur des activités de pop
en Île-de-France nous a rejoint romain
blottas bonsoir bonsoir alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quel est le
quotidien de pop school depuis son
arrivée sur le territoire de 50 ans en
Yvelines en 2019 en fait le territoire
de popsku enfin pas dans le quotidien de
pop school s'est transformé finalement
au quotidien de pop puisque
historiquement en 2019 quand nous sommes
arrivés
popschool avait pour ambition et pour
objectif en accord avec l'agglomération
de 50 ans en Yvelines de s'installer
dans le lieu que nous avons vu tout à
l'heure qui est ce campus numérique de
l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines avec deux
formations dans les domaines de la
cybersécurité et de laïotis et donc sur
l'année 2019-2020 popsku a commencé à
grandir à évoluer d'autres formations
sont arrivées aujourd'hui on fait des
formations dans le domaine du design on
fait des formations dans le domaine de
la médiation numérique avec la formation
actuelle de formateurs et animateurs
numériques donc sont vraiment des
métiers qui sont à la croisée des
chemins entre l'inclusion et la capacité
de pop à faire société et en même temps
le numérique et la capacité à
transmettre le numérique au tout venant
et où tout public Bob school aujourd'hui
travaille aussi avec de nombreux
entreprises on est aussi en relation
avec les écoles puisqu'il y a l'école
200600 qui accueilli certains de nos
jeunes voilà on est de plus en plus
ouvert quand vous dites que vous êtes
ouverte finalement le siège de pop et
thaïlencourt mais vous vous orientez
aussi sur les 12 communes du territoire
notamment on pense à ce summer quand on
peut qui a eu lieu en 2020 où vous êtes
ouvert et bien l'ensemble des 50 chinois
à ce moment-là exactement et en fait ce
summer comme ça a été un peu la genèse
de l'ouverture au groupe et aux autres
activités du groupe donc à l'intérêt de
faire société on s'est mis en
partenariat avec une un autre organisme
de formation au club qui appartient à ce
campus et on a créé un grand événement
d'une quinzaine de jours pour tous les
jeunes qui à l'époque on était dans une
certaine ferm ne pouvait pas sortir du
territoire pour leur proposer une grande
animation d'une quinzaine de journées où
ils étaient sur la découverte des
métiers du numérique et ils ont ouvert
et en fait ce programme à évolué dans le
temps et aujourd'hui nous sommes grâce à
l'agglomération qui est porteur de ce
projet et d'autres acteurs ont travaillé
avec les cités des métiers les centres
sociaux on a plus de 250 partenaires sur
le projet et donc pas pile de France
aujourd'hui porte ce programme ensemble
à 100%. et tout cela romain blotaz donc
avec cette mission d'inclusion mais
surtout l'autre enjeu et c'est ça sera
ma dernière question pour conclure cet
entretien l'autre enjeu c'est vraiment
la formation numérique parce
qu'aujourd'hui et bien ce secteur du
numérique et bien il est en tension et
il y a des besoins énormes en termes de
collaborateurs et de nouveaux
collaborateurs à tous les niveaux et
notre méthode qui est un petit peu
différente d'autres structures ou
d'autres organismes dans le groupe pop
avec aussi des tiers lieux ouverts comme
le pop-caffé dont on a vu les
présentations ou ce type d'autres
activités c'est de d'avoir accès à toute
la chaîne est vraiment d'avoir un
parcours sans couture parce que pour
accéder à une formation il faut se
préparer et parfois les formations du
numérique elle demande quand même un
petit peu de préparation en amont dont
les programmes dont je viens de parler
ont cet intérêt de pouvoir préparer des
personnes à aller sur des formations
plus professionnalisantes ou des
parcours avec plus d'exigences
techniques ou d'exigences en termes de
professionnels ensuite on a les
formations pop School qui donnent
vraiment la valeur ajoutée du métier de
la technicité qui forme des techniciens
et puis pop school travaille aussi et
pop plus généralement à accompagner
réellement les entreprises pour
comprendre les enjeux aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'entreprises du territoire ont
très souvent tendance à s'appuyer sur
des hauts niveaux d'expertise comme des
ingénieurs mais de nombreux techniciens
sont nécessaires pour faire marcher les
entreprises et les formations pop school
les formations que nous proposons les
programmes que nous proposons permettent
déjà en quelques mois parfois en une
année de pouvoir avoir accès à toutes
les compétences pour faire ces tâches
techniciens dans une entreprise et pour
pouvoir aller travailler dans tous les
domaines du numérique et bien merci
beaucoup romain blottes je rappelle donc
que vous êtes coordinateur des activités
de du groupe pop en Île-de-France merci
à vous
[Musique]
bonjour Laurent Legendre directeur
régional et abus développement
bonjour je suis godine Soler je suis la
fondatrice de rachnorec une startup
social qui développe une solution
industrielle de recyclage des plastiques
orphelins pour fabriquer des matériaux
qui viennent remplacer le bois dans
beaucoup de d'applications
[Musique]
on travaille de deux façons différentes
l'une avec Airbus pour la collecte des
masques du site d'Élancourt qui a été
une opération pilote pour prouver la
faisabilité de ce recyclage dans le
process rectorak comme un déchet non
recyclable qu'on peut intégrer dans
notre recette matériaux une grosse
avancée technologique personne ne le
faisait avant c'est la première fois que
ça se fait en France à ma connaissance
et ça nous a paru très intéressant
d'autant plus intéressant on a pu en
faire la promotion pendant le covid et
qu'on a permis de trouver une solution
pour recycler les masques d'Airbus qui
n'étaient pas recyclables et l'autre
c'est une collaboration avec Airbus
développement au travers d'un prêt
participatif Airbus développement a
souhaité nous encourager dans cette
création d'emploi la plus locale
possible autour de son implantation dans
les Yvelines j'ai vu autre chose j'ai vu
aussi un projet industriel sur le
territoire qui va générer des emplois et
qui est en train de faire sa première
implantation industrielle qui est en
train de prendre ses locaux industriels
et il y aura aussi à mon avis des
partenariats parce que avec ces
matériaux là on peut faire aussi du
mobilier urbain
[Musique]
nous a proposé de réaliser des devis
pour différents types d'aménagements des
produits concrets sur mesure pour les
besoins d'Airbus ou des produits plus
standards qui existent déjà dans notre
catalogue le guéridon sur lequel je
m'appuie est un guéridon dans lequel il
y a 10% de masques recyclés et c'est un
guéridon qui frappe probablement
partie du mobilier du site aujourd'hui
on a standardisé le manche debout que
vous voyez ici des bancs des tables
basses et des tabourets on est en train
de créer des bac à plantes on est en
train de créer également des panneaux de
séparation c'est un véritable véritable
pièce utilisable et probablement avec un
prix commercial attractif puisque le
matériau de base ne vaut rien
[Musique]